[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club welcome to plays of
people I am international arbiter
Michael Jake Homer alongside me
Grandmaster Benjamin's Bach Oh st. Louis
Archbishop fame world champions we will
be playing the people today mostly
Benjamin Bach will be playing the people
at game three O rated so this is your
first time playing the people are you
excited yeah definitely also I'm excited
to be joined by a back-to-back world
champion we of course one in San
Francisco with our dear friend Benjamin
Bach and Nicholas Theodore Fabiano and
Julian Pearl eco but we also became
double champions by winning the summer
Series event and we're off to a great
start in 2020 as well three oh no and
we'll be taking on the California
unicorns tomorrow at 3:15 p.m. live and
Caleb Debbie and orsa will be calling
the action yeah yeah we are off to a
great season and like you mentioned all
the players but I think you're
forgetting there the manager as well
who's putting in all the work like when
people in saying let's talk about chess
they talk they don't talk about Fabiano
car why now Wesley Sodor they're talking
about Mike comer you know like
mycommerce one leaving the legacy here
so yeah don't don't forget about him you
know
okay so if you want to go down that road
I'll be I'll be more than happy to
oblige
alright alright so so as you know we've
won two of the three championships all
right in 2017 you here was our team
Wesley so Benjamin Feingold for Cobian
Nicholas Rosenthal team manager Michael
Jay Cutler and of course
the championship it's one a team we got
to the Final Four in San Francisco and
fell a little bit short but got the
bronze medal let's see who the lineup
there was for our Cobian yaro zero
Brooke
Darius fierce and forest Jen team
manager Michael Jake over and then of
course in 2019 we went back and settled
on finished business with Fabiano
Carolina
Benjamin Bach Nicholas Theodore and
Julian T major Michael J color so of all
those 12 spots there was only one repeat
performer for Akopian so but the manager
and hey we got two of the three
championships to prove it all right so
do we have any challenges yet um where
do we see the let's go to that 13 Heat
okay all right we got some challenges
and I will be reading all the comments
here and a centennial you were wrong
you just lost 20 bucks and of course we
have to say hi to our good friend
Aditya Chandra who went to a no
yesterday at chess like it ought to be a
lot of great performance and gain a
perfect 64 chess rating points we are
303 always fine I but all rated chess
we're here to where do you layer keeps
right
[Music]
okay so do we have a do we have a match
going oh yeah but he hasn't moved yet
all right we can just probably axe abort
the game and then no we don't want a
rematch
let's get let's get somebody once heals
Carlos I know he wants casual and
unloaded oh boy oh boy
can we play forever all right all right
let's go - lets go with uh how about
this guy happy ain't a happy pause all
right all right everyone we're playing a
happy pull and we're a pawn up so we're
happy I never give it back never never
give it back
all right he's going for some sneaky
gambits well it's not gonna work against
us all right we are working as a team
today so I am eligible to commence but
it might be for the benefit of the
viewers so you never know
well you'll be sometimes allowed to call
a move I'm not sure what he's doing here
I'll just do this
oh no I blundered my queen I guess I
didn't that's too bad c3 oh is he taking
my bishop all right those keeping score
it o 1 and O yep yep let's see who's
next get some more system raided what
about this Raven guy he thinks he's
really good 2116 oh yes expert so this
might be a little bit tougher than the
last all right so he goes need for it's
played a NIMS oh no Jax
was that a mouse slip oh no that's just
what it would play generally oh yeah so
you guys don't know at home maybe
Benjamin Bach can take some solace on
this too so if you ever like are
touching your pawn and don't want to
move it you just take his king put it on
the white king uh okay yeah and that
that way right one you might win you
might just get that capture the king or
two no don't just put the pawn back on
gg5 RG or wherever where it came from
so now if you're playing like blitz here
like alive you know are you actually
going to be showing like your main stuff
or you just like fooling around putting
oh I'm just fooling around like I'm
keeping all myself for the protest Lee
cuz we're for to another world champion
yeah yeah yeah and Geoffrey Zhang
he's our secret weapon he has not played
yet but I have a feeling that in
February we are going to unleash him so
we're gonna unleash the Geoffrey show so
watch out our opponents in February
including the number one team currently
the Canada chess bras yeah Canada chess
bras they're probably our biggest rivals
for the World Championship
yeah they have Eric Hanson as their
manager but we've got mycommerce so he's
got to be a player managers yep
never underestimate that it's like the
playing tournament director very
difficult very yeah so I mean I know
everyone wanted to have you know Mike as
a player on the street on the on the
team but like Mike took a step back he
decided like nope not doing that I'm
just focusing on my managerial duties
and we're going for another world
championship yeah we actually have two
slots still open this year and I guess I
have yet to put myself on the team
because I would get an even bigger cut
of our big bonus check but I have
resisted the urge
Thomas says hi guys hello hello Demetri
so I think we're doing pretty well or
pawn up and we're off on the clock
he's going for some tricks now with
Queen a5 are we scared of that though no
we're not oh you can just take your
Bishop huh rook takes Bishop but then I
take back oh then your Knights also
protected by your Brooke I did not yeah
did not say that oh we're going smaller
is there any way to get it back I don't
know I'm not a tag guy mm let's see
oh my god every tick with the patient
body plays rook d7 but does it even
matter
yeah it'll take them b5 it's a bit
annoying okay I'll just stick with the
rook I guess though it looks a bit risky
cuz I want to keep the pawn yeah but he
goes he goes Bishop d3 so we got to be
careful of those tricks always let's
just try to exchange the Queen's not
sure of how I played this this guy
bravenwolf is playing a pretty decent so
giving us a good match yep yep okay
we're still pulling up and we exchanged
[Music]
yeah cuz here at the same lose chess
club we're building champions so yeah
get your chances then we're playing
three overrated this game is gonna be
over pretty pretty quick yeah I'll be
rated as a Olympic up Alaska says only
rated yep yep we're only playing real
games here alright if Maximus or Trisha
see if you put in a three-hour ated
challenge we'll accept it
oh no I blunder my rook guess I didn't
all right Maximus is on here now we
can't find you unfortunately oh yeah we
can take another challenge from this guy
Knight Rio yeah so just everyone make
sure that you wait why are we always
playing with black like
secret challenge like yeah I'm playing
white though I don't know if that's
embedded in the thing or not all right
would you approve this mic the modern
defense I like to play the dragon
Sicilian so it's kind of a kind of like
yeah transpose into it you you [ __ ]
cover to and oh all right all right so
they are keeping track in the back room
okay they're not just like they're
fooling around all right all right so
we're going for the double fianchetto
you know it's channeling the bishops are
good on the diagonal so all right let's
see what it's going to come up with oh
we already increased a lot of rating
2197 now yep yep if we started what 1662
yeah I wonder how it got that low yeah
sometimes arrived chess associates and
aren't as good as me and Benjamin play
and uh kind of crushed our rating and
then we have to get it back up yep
well we get it a good job already yeah
so you've got the center but we should
be fine here
so yeah if you are in st. Louis today I
want to play some chess at the Chess
Club we do have a tournament for you
today does Sunday 6 players swiss so
it's $10 to enter 6 player sections and
2 prizes $40 for the winner
$20 for second place in the six players
Swiss so that good registration ends at
2:45 it starts at 3 o'clock ends by 5
old pro chess League time controls game
15 plus 2 second increment now this
idiots game 10 with a 2 second increment
to kind of speed it along and if you
come to the st. Louis chess club you can
also meet a legend in person Michael J
comer I will be directing the chess
tournament so who knows maybe I'll play
in it if if I'm the number one seed in
in section number 2 then I was playing
it for sure alright so we could take the
pawn on d4 but it might have been a bit
tricky because like he would have some
tricks on the D foul so I'm just gonna
bite of 61 yep yep play solid yep I'm
not taking any risks here now discovered
attack on the night - well he said yeah
at least I think he will all right
[Music]
what's that not even do it on d6 no you
got enough enough hit the asar taught me
that but the farther our Knights down
there the less squares he's attacking
and he's just like beginner mistake well
I guess you stopping you from playing
see ya all right you guys rookie one
will we take the pawn Mike yes we will
the time and now we're threading e5 well
if I hang tonight but 6 we're
threatening we could go night a 4 into 5
where in his head yep yeah only got 20
seconds to figure it out
he's in the red yeah and so you see like
a night on these sakes looks nice but
eventually you'll just you'll you'll
just blunder it so don't do that
it's not good now he's blundered upon
him be - and he's got ten seconds left
so he spoon of a great game but he's
going down in flames anyway you got to
bring a better game to the table if you
want to be to me my comer who's next
we gotta get raided what about toasted
we yeah we go back to chess experts well
I'm I'm black again like black again
well just get used to it
all right he's going before well you
like the dragon you set some fee and
getting my bishop begin or a Kings
Indian kind of defense yep yep well I
guess it thicker well I guess he could
be played to c4 I guess it wouldn't be
quite okay so we're gonna put in the pan
oh very ation where you go with a six
Ruby a and B five consider yeah so the
point is you try to exchange the c4 pawn
for the b5 pawn so you get more control
over the center for baby huh yeah let's
figure out okay let's try to bring this
Knight back - can I draw arrows here
like this yeah beautiful because the
night is like on the deck yeah so now we
know tonight's not in danger anymore
like it yep yep playing it solid here
not taking any risks yep because then we
get more control over all the light
squares oh he's not allowing us to do so
let's try to attack let's try to take
the center like this
so we got it kind of kind of like a
hippo because we got both the Knights on
these seven and the bishops yank it out
but it should be pretty good hippo for
us I guess are you gonna strike with c5
or f5 sometime tomorrow I'm keeping that
for now
like just protecting the pawn okay so
now we'll put the Knight to c4 Knight d2
that's but that's hanging the d2 pawn
all his pieces are so overworked now yep
yep so yeah if he takes a pawn on d5
then ninety four columns attacking the
knight and the bishop that would be a
rookie mistake and we don't make those
at the same Louis just full of all right
we got 90 for checking the bishop see
what he does
yeah base of a one's not even on that's
good yeah that hangs the pawn right so
we're doing pretty well here I'll try to
activate my other pieces as well and
we're up on the clock
he's only got one minute left yes blue
blue it gives a poll will we take it
uh-huh
we could always take that later it's
just activate the Queen first but I
guess you could play Knight to be one
here I guess yeah but N Queen a6 all
right so he's giving us the pawn again
will we take it no we don't even need it
we'll just activate our queen Yaser
would be very disappointed in you yeah
if you see a free pawn take it all right
he's going d5 are we scared of such
banana shenanigans um guess we're not so
what do we do here Mike yeah let's just
go I don't know get that pawn and be
happy
yep let's take the a3 pawn no matter
what no matter no matter what that pawn
is going for evil pretty much
well not pre moving Queen takes 83
because he could all right he's gone 92
okay mm-hmm I should have taken it
earlier when I had the chance
no should have listened to the manager
let's go for some counter play right
there with f5 yep yep okay so the center
is opening up for him and he's pretty
long time
there should be two never gonna get that
part
all right we'll just go we'll just go
we'll just take and go mmm I don't know
let's make a move like Bishop h6 I don't
know just double the rooks right the
pace he's in the red zone here all right
let's all right tripled up on the up on
okay let's try to trap this Queen she
doesn't watch on oh we got oh and you
fell for it
that's the Queen so you see if you don't
manage your time you'll blunder your
pieces rookie mistake right there okay
you might play Knight d5 here yep all
right there goes the room and boom the
checkmates coming in yep all right so
said yeah you stepped it up but not not
good enough to have a chance against us
so what do we know let's see if all
maximus is on here is Maximus all right
what about this Aditya guy
Aditya all right oh do we play with
whydo I don't think we're black then all
right Mike you got to change this like
we got to figure out a way to so we can
be we got a start
all right Aditya you got your you got
your wish a teacher so make the most of
it you're playing a real-life chess
grandmaster here at the st. Louis just
close all right let's go for another few
in cat I put the bishop on b7 and what
is he gonna do f3 on out now they're
getting used to your openings now
they've seen yeah that's why we got to
switch it up every now and that yeah
Bishop g5
yeah if anybody has any suggestions in
the chat how we can play as the white
pieces let us know okay so if you're
sick of all these King Indians yeah we
can switch it up and we promise we won't
play at least on our first game night of
three okay okay okay
at least on our first date
yep so he's going pretty aggressive
against us but yeah we'll see how that
will work out for him um let's just put
the night mm-hmm I just put a night bag
I will try to tag the center later with
c5 might be a bit risky because he's got
a lot of space but we got faith all
right let's give a check here I like yep
yep cuz g3 hangs the rook we're always
thinking one step ahead here are the
same loose just so he can play Oh
Bishop F to not see that happening yeah
I'm not sure about dad let's just take
castles and we'll just blow up the
center alright um what are we doing now
let's just play f6 try to open up if he
takes we'll take back with a queen
yeah yep yeah yeah we got the time edge
we got the rating edge we are a real
life chess master now you got us from
1602 chess master like that yep yep that
was great
so I read on your bio yesterday that it
was your birthday yesterday yeah it was
yeah it was my birthday yesterday
celebration so this is like your
birthday weekend
yeah just happy to give give back to
like you said give back to the people
you know all right let's bring in the
Knights and try to go for some tricks
okay yeah and we got the time again so a
deejay has to step it up at some point
but I mean must be pretty intimidating
playing like again someone who's managed
by a world champion they said right next
I'll give them all the great yeah what
chance do you really have yeah he's
right he's right good I mean you got a
you got it yeah at least he took the
game to you at least he tried you know
so I kind of respect them for that all
right let's take and bring in the other
night
just remove the defenders you know so so
your first appearance as a st. Louis
Archbishop yep was playing the game two
came 10+2 the Battle Royale in the
protest League right yeah at olds last
year so yeah that was my first
appearance and yeah I'm also happy to
have made my debut for this year yes
Oh didn't he just hang the night Mike
this game is in the books this game is
in the books yep yes so do you like
playing that game 10 plus 2 or the game
15 plus 2 uh yeah I like I like both but
yeah temples too maybe a little bit more
because I like blitz is my best time
control so I feel like the faster it
gets student is generally better for me
say a templates to probably write the
u.s. collegiate rapid and blitz you did
take home some hardware in the Blitz
category yeah yep I won the silver like
I came second right behind Darius
teammate of mine and at the Midwest
collegiate blitz championship I won so I
increased my rating in both tournaments
yeah we can play we combine Miska all
right let's see what you got Miska our
misc
a4 you never know maybe they'll start up
with everyone's going d4 here yep so
we're going for an utterly modern
defense and let's go I don't know Knight
of 6 okay so we got some kind of Kings
Indian here like a king's indian
actually let's try to get him out of
book somehow
Oh mister it's only a name I am
celebrating my birthday today
but it's a few days early it's always
cool yeah yeah just stretch out your
birthday like you had you been had his
birthday today but he's still
celebrating right here yeah yeah when
you have a birthday week
yeah just celebrate it as much as you
can just celebrate it all year through
you know like right yeah that's how you
gotta live your life every day is a
celebration all right so he's weakened
the light squares around his King big I
think yeah
rookie mistake right there and we'll try
to take advantage of debt oh let's just
exchange the night's and now we're
preventing them from ever playing a four
so yep bring it bringing the night okay
he takes it that's another mistake now
we got this strong Bishop who just came
to life bring out the Queen yeah we can
always Jackie we can always check yeah
yep yep but not well not when you're
Queens on and if he's not careful he's
gonna fall into some tricks all right so
that so King H 1 is of course strongly
recommended in this position yeah yes to
do something about Bishop H Street I
don't know what I think that's the only
move in this position King H one yeah
and he found it all right I can play
like a 1,400 all right so we got the
Bishop on e5 pretty solid once again
there's bishops just controlling the
board and ok he's trying to bring the
knight back to the defense but it's not
gonna work for him I doubt it well
what's Bishop d7 going to do we'll just
take him d5 I mean is he really going
for this pawn he is he is miss k4 so he
loves that a vile it's gonna be hard to
crack through here let's be greedy like
yes or you know like he likes a pawn so
we'll protect them right all right
let's see what he does we'll just try to
put okay he goes bishop be fine that's
actually pretty good move because I
wanted to play Bishop d7 but he was one
step ahead of us okay let's try to it's
a pity but sometimes you got to do what
you got to do I bet he's gonna attack
your rook with Queen okay yeah yeah
let's put this rook here and let's
double up on the C file all right he
takes don't give them a passed pawn yeah
big mistake big mistake all right
actually whatever he found king h1 he's
kind of picked it up a little bit yeah
it's playing pretty well now it's not
gonna be easy to win this game but we'll
we'll try but I think we have to what
about rook to c5 but he can take that
and then okay bad idea bad idea yeah
let's just take and put put the King
here to get out of any checks okay that
might be a big mistake is he no he isn't
not in the box he's not in the Box gotta
make sure you were in there yep yep if
you would have taken Mike's lessons at
the same loose Chess Club about pawn and
games this morning
yep according to Adrienne Daigle yep if
you where did he say what did he say oh
we we can we'll accept
odd row eighty ones challenge and we can
play as the white pieces next time okay
you're not all right nice try buddy all
right I'm not sure what he's doing here
yeah well I always always go for the
stop yeah there we have the checkmate
oh yeah but good game Miska
yeah yeah like we got a nice position
out of the opening then he stepped it up
really well so all right so a Adriene
hey I drew odd row let's see if we can
find odd row you guaranteed us if we
outro if we end up being the black
pieces we're gonna abort the game - yeah
and you'll never get a thing again
all right well here's Maximus he's been
begging for a game over
oh we're black again of course of course
it's d4 once again well let's play
another I'll get like next game we'll do
something else okay yeah okay all right
so we're taking the center right away
we're losing no time okay so let's take
this guy and go Knight to c6 if he takes
will reinforce our center miss Csokas
says good game good game yeah yep yep
thanks all right
let's take the pawn on b2 with the
bishop and the rook c3 let's go h5 let's
have some fun Wow
nobody oh I hate it when they play that
yeah all right let's bring on the night
those guys I guess good still
theoretically play forward but yeah it
doesn't really worry us
it doesn't yeah I think the opening went
pretty well for us let's just play d6
yep
and yeah we got nice pressure on the B
file we can go alright so now we see the
advantage of going h4 h5 like we have a
nice night on g4 and now he can't attack
it anymore
with h2 h3 so that's always the point of
going this f3 would be a rookie mistake
Queen b6 oh wow yeah I'm always a fan of
never playing my f pawns but now I know
why no yep
all right let's go Bishop a6 so yeah
this [ __ ] was controlling this diagonal
nice okay let's go 95 try to try to get
a knight to d3 leaf in the wind maybe we
will play you next in the wind we'll try
we'll try that way we'll get the white
pieces
all right everyone
so yeah you have to do something about
93 Queen see - nice try buddy let's just
bring out the Queen yep like rule number
one always try to activate all of your
pieces wonderful and now he's got
problems a fella peeing like he can't
move the rook here because that runs to
Bishop III
a4 like what is dead it's like get out
of here Queen it's not a champion move
all right it's time to cash in
we'll go 90 three take the bishop and
then take that pawn this
you can like improve your pieces you
can't even play but that's one point you
just got a cash in you know like you got
to take the pawn yep thank you very much
all right he's giving us another pawn
will we take it yes we will it's almost
too easy
this guy waited a long time to play us -
I mean it's not easy playing like no
dude you're being watched by yeah the
manager of the same loose just Club I
think I figured out who be easy is all
right
okay so I'm trying to get the rook to b8
how hard is it yeah there yeah
okay um let's go let's try to win by
some tricks you you know you fell for it
sometimes you just want to expedite the
game yep
all right let's let's get who's next
let's see let's get leaf in the wind he
guaranteed we'll all of the white pieces
oh thank you very much okay what do you
like Mike II for defense all right I
like the delay Knight c3 yep yep let's
keep him guessing you know alright
Bishop g4 trying to take the center not
sure about that buddy okay let's just
castle now once again we keep him
guessing new we gonna do we want to go
93 or yeah
we'll go for c4 grab some more space
let's go Queen d3 you take that pawn
right there let's go can we go [ __ ]
before or if you want to if you want to
have some fun let's just I mean could
always just play Queen c8 right yeah but
that would be a big concession for him
let's just go in Knight c3 you're
getting away with it this time freezer
the next time next time will punish you
for such lousy moves I mean well we have
a great position anyway h3 you just
trying to trick us by taking the night
and then get that pawn there but we're
not going to blunder daddy's you know no
way let's just develop the pieces all
right um let's put this rook here
just rook right there work on the same
file as the Queen a five I don't know
just play a three whatever
you
so yeah we got more space so he's giving
a pong we'll just take it now except
prove it prove it
yep now you gotta prove it freezer if
you don't have any comp will have to
pawn yeah where's the coke
where's the calm bro where's the calm I
mean like I should get to play with the
same loose archbishops you know you
can't afford any risks like that cuz cuz
mike is ruthless you know he'll just
throw you out of the team all right and
it's it's that mentality that almost got
Fabiano a world championship but he just
he just fell short you know only I feel
like his biggest mistake was not taking
you to the match in New York I was
really thinking about that yeah in our
interview right in San Francisco he even
said he even said well maybe if I had
Mike on my team maybe it would have
worked out different and that'sa let's
that's on that's on YouTube so that's
that's public record yeah all right he
just went c5 weakening some squares but
that's not gonna work for him Oh things
a lot manager let's just move the Queen
back all right all right safe and sound
yeah so it's really the teamwork that
you see right here that's bringing us
all the World Championships
shout out to gauges
is this WCM I receive let if ya just
give us your hang your handle iris Z and
you might be able to accept your
challenge I'm at stake here you take for
the bishop we might have some tricks
would route these six if you approve of
that let's have some fun it's long time
anyway yep yep yeah if you take for the
bishop Queen is hanging right if you
move the Queen he's gonna run into
something like I'll take at that point I
would just say Wow ten seconds I would
just take the room yeah take the knight
and get two for one and see what happens
but it's too late now this game is in
the books
yep no it's times about to run out
you know yep alright he put up a nice
fight with the Scandinavian but not
quite good enough alright let's play I'm
of course the National arbiter Michael J
comer team manager of the world champion
the reigning champion Archbishop's
alongside is fellow st. Louis Archbishop
teammate and world champion Benjamin
Duke and we are taking on three O rated
challenges and so far we are eight and
no unblemished yeah so he's going for a
five but I mean I don't know buddy it's
only gonna yeah what is he doing
anything that's not good that's I'm
gonna work for you you know like we'll
just stake here we'll go for in next
game right so when they have a question
mark that that means they don't even
know what they're rated and uh this guy
is they not even rated 1342
unfortunately yep
alright so iris now we're have been
challenged by wcm iris all right so you
to go c6 we'll take that then he'll
probably exchange Queens with we'll take
back with the night and he's still got
oh oh oh buddy yeah
that's game make sure you can just bring
him Queen takes d7 no you can also put
the Queen here but we can we can dream
of this yep oh yeah yeah you did your
trick you did your trick all right that
still would have been technique right
because Queen takes and then Queen takes
pawn checkmate right Oh
so if you play Queen d7 oh yeah so I I
play different way than you planned it
good you play good all right so let's
get st. Louis and one dead as WCM iris
ow there we go all right we have a title
player yep challenging us let's see what
he's good you see uh iris iris ow is a
female
w w CM alright so we'll try to confuse
him here with the opening you know it's
making think early on yep I don't know
let's just do something gauges also says
sometimes the question marks also means
they don't know engines are cheating oh
I don't know what that really means so
so is it not advisable to play people
with a question mark I don't know we'll
just crush them yeah you don't if you
lose in 30 moves with an engine like
this engine is from like the year 1600
or something it's better to use your own
brain than losing 16 move or 13 moves
that's why I really like these fast time
controls ya know increment or delay I
mean ya know you know you probably don't
even have that much time done yeah you
don't like cheaters here the same lose
chess club we're rebuilding champions
here yes
all right so we'll just try to play
against these weak pawns and yeah let's
see if we can get something working you
know so this is iris out she actually
led our team to victory against Suk
Diddy the baby Archbishop's she was
bored one and we prevailed in a match
one and match knew not so much maybe
we'll have to do a tiebreaker
all right um let's take back like this
and yeah once again we'll try to attack
these weak pawns okay you say they're
weak they look kinda formidable to me
but we'll see we'll see yeah they're
fine for now yeah I don't know let's
just put the rook here I guess you say
you're not afraid of before I mean d4
it's a move but we'll move the rook back
and then we're threatening tricks with
964 yeah let's just move the route back
here scary stuff scary stuff and now it
is Paula this week again you know so
we'll let's just go rook here I tagged
this guy for the--for we'll go III oh
the Queen oh let's go III like now you
can go d4 anymore oops
yeah so he's played this pretty well
like the last couple moves but I still
like our position let's go night here go
for some cheapos eirick d8 obviously is
coming yep and let's bring out the Queen
go for some more cheapos you know like
if you don't know what you're doing just
go for some cheap trick
about Queenie six yeah and we'll bring
the knight back all right
yep and he does it or isn't it it's a
she oh she sorry I don't you see him I
was out so she wants to go d4 let's just
take the Queen and put it up yep let's
go
do we have any tricks let's just put the
Queen here so probably we threaten to
take here cuz like this rook will always
be hanging at the very end holder
captures you know so you see WCM woman's
can't a master I was out playing very
well but yeah Grand Master's are
relentless
they'll never they'll never give in no
just you pounding pounding away creating
all these little weaknesses and
eventually you're gonna fold either not
on the board but on time all right so we
can take the pawn here I guess if we
take takes back we'll take again I don't
know like let's just take it one more
time we are not open for any chess
variants so don't even
challenge us all right let's take here
go
let's take here and go 95 yep yep so we
got Queen g6 okay yeah we'll take and
bring the night bag off is okay yeah now
we got the pawn mission accomplished all
right let's put the rook on the seventh
let's keep it ponder tech all right um
let's go chief for five Oh
let's go h3 big check okay yeah let's
move up the king I'd be four I'm just
playing pretty well but we're well you
see but playing well all day buddy bet
it's just too late it's just too late
but we'll try to get the the w anyway oh
let's just I don't know play King up my
dare let's play here yeah not too sure
of my technique here but it doesn't
matter
two seconds one second yeah let's bring
the knight back yep
oh yeah it's good number that's a good
number
yeah but good game saying Louis and one
yeah yeah she defend really well so
who's next like who has been betting on
for a challenge
I drew one says I bet you can't beat I
drove a t1 auto 81 I gauntlet has been
thrown let's go for d4 it is good okay
what kind of opening do you like Mike
I like d4 c4 Knight c3 and then I think
that's the most solid of all yeah okay I
don't know let's go for prettiest stuff
yep he's going for the Kings in Ian
be six really huh so you're just yeah
let's just go for some tricks you know
you might think okay
ninety-six yeah oh oh there you go
mandro yeah yep you got to bring
something better than the table if
you're playing a grandmaster oh we can
doesn't even like oh this is punishment
that's not even fair yep yep you better
play e5 real quick or something to make
I don't need 85 97 and doesn't work
they'll have no spots for your queen yep
Queens trips so it's looking tough for
ya Oh does that help him at all queen c8
maybe 97 it so yep nice try mister andro
but you're going down all right let's
just stake back bring bag tonight all
right yep we can take a pawn so we'll
take it
yep yeah nice try by Andrew 81 but like
Mike said to be world champions need to
bring something better to the table
because we're ruthless you you know all
right bring out the bishop Harvey the
broad asked Mike have you ever played
Benjamin before I have luckily never had
the pleasure and never one to I did get
a good game against former Webster
windmill Dennis burrow in a game 30 D
zero game oh and I thought I had I
thought I want a piece yeah so as we're
talking he he said he's sacrifice
another rook but I'm not sure if that's
gonna okay play King he's got four
pieces you have five pieces and a queen
I like your chances so yes to like go
King h8 dudes for defense you know boots
for defense all right
please don't resign here because I
wanted to show like if he goes here
we'll give a check he goes back we'll
give another check he goes back Queen h8
he takes it knight of seven check me
look it's yeah it's a wonderful
checkmate
all right who's next
Chad who wants to really play Newcombe
plays we got your back we got your back
all right
so let's go for something different this
time let's go for uh what's it called at
Torres system it's very solid all right
let's bring onto Bishop I'm not sure
about that
okay oh let's try to gain some space
over there
97 okay um that hangs upon yeah I mean
if you're gonna hang a pawn to move from
nine you know like at least have some
kind of compensation I guess it is not
complete loss yeah it's just hopeless
I think after taking oh and he he's
second oh well he's got rook e8 so he'll
get some stuff back but we'll take
another pawn be greedy you know and
let's bring the bishop back to the age
four square so we have this square for
our night because I I could have put it
on a three but then I can develop my
knight anymore but always trying to
think one step ahead okay let's bring
out the night and now we have ninety
five tricks but he wants to do some
stuff here so not letting we're not
letting that happen
Thanks you know we'll take it back we
have to do you fall now buddy yeah let's
bring out the night yep yep Bishop f6 I
don't know why this guy wants to trade
into a losing end game but yeah let's
just move up the King yep so we got two
extra pawns and I guess I took plenty of
chess lessons from Mike I know how to
convert now i leaf in the wind that you
already got the play so once you get to
play you know we got a lot of people in
there yep in the queue and unfortunately
there will be no rematches today alright
so let's just put the rook here try to
wipe out the entire seven rank all right
we'll just take play G three it's just
completely okay yeah we got a winning
pawn and getting here I think we can
pretty move pretty much everything here
let's do this I mean check okay we'll
just try to can make multiple premiums
here no just one okay that's the big
difference between our wonderful account
on chess comm what you know of course
supports the protest League you can make
multiple free moves but every time you
do make a pre move on chest i com
you lose point one second yep but on
here
just one pre move allowed alright so
yeah we'll just we'll just take all his
pawns if I take an auto pawn no we're
not letting king knee five happen no
counter play limit the counter plan yeah
all they can do was resign yep
all right do we have anyone else who
really wants to play us according to
leaf in the wind yeah we didn't play him
nothing sounds right watch me well let's
be nice to him all right well leaf in
the wind all right it says zeros here
okay so I guess he was telling the truth
all right yep very honest guy leap in
the wind so okay let's play let's see
let's see what he does
let's play the lawn at this time I gotta
calm skis
yep secret weapon yes all right um we'll
just develop here
let's make a square for the bishop so he
can always draw back under any
circumstance
yeah we got 93 players watching now all
right yep can we break a hundred
so yeah the lawn system it's pretty
solid you just develop your pieces you
don't need really need to worry about
anything so you just put the bishop here
tonight here the bishop here and like
night usually it goes to t2 and then you
take it from there I wonder what he's
thinking about I mean it looks like a
pretty easy opening to play against you
are to play as both colors I mean this
should not take you a minute and ten
seconds of your chess expert to make
what your ninth or eighth move come on
yeah just yeah Mike Mike we're not
approve of dead I mean you used like one
third of your time already and it's not
even moved ten that's all right you know
you're almost half your time yeah and
I'm not a winning formula there's no
increment yeah you can't get bailed out
like in the pro chest league so our big
match this week is against the
California unicorns yep so two players
that wanted to be an archbishop this
year are playing for the unicorns their
number one board your your your teammate
its Lou Darius words is going to
actually leaving the California report
and then Gregory operan from Mizzou
chess Fame University of
missouri-columbia
will be playing as well he actually has
a 2707 rapid rating so Oh even though
we're favored in all 16 Kings it might
be a little bit like do you see the
trick do I see a trick probably you're a
Bishop to c7 yep
that Queen is going nowhere so actually
I did when I used to do the beginner
breakdown
program back in June 14th 2015 I
actually had two two episodes called
don't lose the Queen and that's how they
lost the Queen they always get corralled
in by that Bishop yeah the long limb
system is pretty tricky you know you
think that Bishop is doing nothing over
there but then you don't watch out for
one move and it is coming after you
so let's just love it love it and give a
big we'll take here and now tonight oh
yeah job yep this guy's time management
was bad as tactics were bad it was like
but I'm glad we got to play you got glad
we got to play yeah yep happy too long
yeah like we're happy to give anyone a
game all right so we're a queen up but
does he have enough compensation all
right let's take another pawn all right
we're attacking the rook he sees it we
can take another poet on the app let's
just take another pawn and now some
let's go g4 let's see Nagi seven oh yeah
the old back road checkmate yeah red
Bobby Fischer teaches chest buddy
all right let's see who's next is there
anyone online the Chad wants a game
magaz Kanna once one Magus hey Zeus
Chris hey Zeus Chris we're going with
Boris man let's played this guy all
right
expert another chess expert let's see
who see what we do look just so what do
you want to play Mike what opening oh
you like the sefa
se5 is always fun I don't know let's
play this ooh
Antron see is kind of calling you out
for the next game all right
Anton see okay we'll give him a game
well we'll try to find you if we can't
find you well can't find you okay so you
might be yeah okay bottom c3 is kind of
weak so let's try to take advantage of
that with the rook here shout-out to
Jack Martine b3 well doesn't just runs
in 295 big mistake buddy you would never
do something like that right I like
Queen b6 I'm not really a big fan of
Queen b3 my queen doing other stuff yeah
oh let's just play I don't know let's
put the night here
back to be effective b3 yeah let's go
Bishop e7 you know I'll develop okay
night C night sorry 92 um we'll just
we'll just annoy him you know let's give
the Knights on the board some been fine
go used to have a trick where he will
put his queen on a four I guess they
would get attacked he put it on d1 and
then played Queen to h5 then like like a
triangle thing I don't know if any other
grandmasters really do that okay I don't
know what that's up if that's a real
maneuver third let's try to Oh try to
this guy's actually ahead on time no so
you know stay here he's okay now all
night again yeah okay the knight on c4
again this guy's gotta figure this out
okay and let's double the rooks maybe
was listening to us queen h5 let's go
checkmate attack go and
okay yeah wool will let them exchange
the night's like it really wants to like
whatever let's go be five try to soften
up the pawn structure over here yeah
this gets to start thinking about
checkmate here cuz you have no defenders
on your Kings side yeah I mean maybe
Bishop f8 but good luck he needed to get
on the ball
I mean work b3 ain't gonna cut it okay
you're playing a grandmaster here okay
um let's just go I don't know let's go
Queen here try to take his weaknesses I
don't know what's going on on the B file
so it's so good okay
oh let's put I don't know let's plate
she's six I guess but it's not hard to
it's not easy to break through here on
their on the Queen side so he's putting
up a solid defense on time somehow
let's go Queen a4 where you got a game
we got a game yep yep okay now let's go
b4 let's give it to him he takes we
might just take him d4 you know he needs
to take what the rookie if he knows
what's good for him but that that's too
much no like I'll take with the bishop
oh yeah good point good point good point
yeah so just to figure out what he wants
to do here okay f5 interesting but we're
not afraid of that no way no way he can
try some rugby seven okay he takes we'll
just take back our king is pretty save
over here then you got this pawn
marching down the board and we're ahead
on time alright alright okay we'll take
an auto palm buddy
which it's always nice oh we can just we
can just take them c2 in the next one
yeah it's not hard to win when you have
two guys playing one guy how did how did
how do you know he's not at home with
all his cronies yeah you don't know you
don't know what this guy's
- all right so yeah he played okay just
give up yeah well on the next move we
can take on c2 and if he takes Jack was
just too much once he gets checked these
say no I don't throw it in the yeah yeah
who's who's next Jack Dibb has my back
yeah who says the other guys lon okay
all right let's see what we got where's
Aunt Wanda's
you know these ones - yeah let's play he
was calling you out - he was calling you
well he's like yeah we got to the master
level really quick like within like four
games maybe three four games inside that
unit it's just even though we win every
game our radio only goes up a little I
guess I guess in real life that's got to
be a kind of not dramatic but it's kind
of like dang yeah oh really I mean you
have to be good consistently over a long
period of time to become a grandmaster
it's no no joke don't just give off the
title yeah so we got a santur here he's
gonna Knight each fight but like we
don't fall for for stuff like that okay
let's let's put the bishop here
and we'll try to go aggressive on this
guy you know he's trying to make fun of
us with moves like b6 like what is he
doing
okay so for just a lot of Oh like yeah
it's got to be careful you know right
what's my it's on the real or groom our
Grimm exactly all right night in the
center well it's just a free night
another free night base up the b7 I
guess big threat yes yes to try some
tricks but it's not gonna work
Bishop d6 alright oh let's just put them
let's just take here Wow yeah and take
the knight all right buddy
so we got Queen of three coming next
might wait enough three my try to take
some more more stuff always gonna be
taking stuff yep
Queen h4 he's sex it let's let's play
for the people you know let's go for
checkmate checkmate alright yep so we're
threatening here we're threatening here
he's got nothing on us I think it take
your H pawn might as well yeah there we
go Antoine all right so we got a
checkmate coming in oh yeah let's give a
check here bishops gonna deliver the
final blow it looks like or two Queen
are the Queen out right Benjamin sees
everything that's right play Karl V
please okay Karl V if we can find
ourselves a game and thank you for the
majority of the players especially the
people that are doing saying please play
me please please thank you for following
the instructions of three Oh braided
yeah
it really helps speed things along
yep all right we got ourselves another
Kings Indian so let's see let's see what
kind of setup he does because there are
a lot of setup so I can choose from your
plaintiff or really put the pressure on
H stream okay let's go eat 5 D 5 let's
go 85 so we want to put the night here
and once we put the night on c5 it can
never be bought
buttered by b4 so we're going trying to
go from F 5 yeah you never played G 4 I
thought that would be the follow-up to
h3 g4 right well that's food this night
here so we can
let's just go at 5 no that's what the
King's Indian is all about I think we're
doing pretty well here we got our f5
counter play going and 92 well let's
let's see let's try to let's just go
bish with you Sally you know just
develop
maybe next move we can go a four and all
right he goes f4 probably trying to stop
you from playing up for well let's just
take this guy and yeah okay he takes
back with the bishop
let's just go Queen seven you know we're
keeping it simple just developing our
pieces this rook is coming to e8 our
Knights are controlling quite a bit of
squares around the center okay he goes
Oh any trade 93 right oh we also have Fe
you know like attacking this Bishop and
this one yep alright he decided to
sacrifice the bishop I guess just didn't
see it probably it just didn't see it
yeah Oh play it alright and then yep
that's what happens when you play
grandmasters it's uh yep thanks for the
game alright everyone let's use next
anyone to check out whatever does it say
claims it's his birthday he's a birthday
boy - uh who's who's claiming it's his
birthday
I'm whatever on whatever all right we'll
give him a game well we got it we got it
we gotta bring it though we're sixteen -
no yep this is this is huge this is huge
this birthday alright so I might have to
help you on this one so it's his
birthday big check out right if you
support that you give off the checks
give up it all right so take this bishop
alright Bishop e2 oh he took he took big
mistake alright so it's all ready all
right let's bring on the night
before I will take that you take speck
with the night yeah it's you can do that
but we got the two bishops now I think
we're doing great
probably bring Queen to d2 and probably
bring down yeah we'll just castle here
this guy waiting for all right let's do
the rook on the half-open falling and
here comes Lane to D to maneuver will
play b phi trying to gain some space
here
a3 let's put the Queen here this
position is pretty solid though let's
play rook here I don't know so yeah so
this is actually so on whatever is up
five to four against the team at the st.
Louis chess club so this is our chance
to even it up the score
oh we just played like the play nine
times against us and uh won five lost
four yep all right so we're taking this
pawn see what he does about it might be
three that's hanging that guy over there
will we take it yes we will of course of
course
yep yeah we're not gonna be greedy we're
not gonna be greedy my plays book b1
we're going right back to g7 we're going
right we can also go to c3 we're gonna
be here yeah I like I like it I like yep
yep oh he didn't see the oh but there
maybe there was nothing I could even do
yeah you'll probably just lost like this
position is just collapsing
okay Queen d3 trading into a end game
when your pieces down it's not a good
idea buddy
bringing in the rook or even bad or even
better we're gonna everybody were to say
go to the second Drago he's gonna wipe
out on the third ring yep yep
all right let's take this Lord thinks
he's gonna play us a good game here
96 not at some he's trying to go over
some tricks here but it's not gonna work
against us
Bishop f2 will just take here rookie
said no because that checkmate yep yeah
well maybe like our pawn so we'll keep
this guy f4 let's play it solid yeah
yeah you never especially when you're
winning you don't want to play crazy
never give them hope to eliminate hope
and then just get bored of the guy to
result a counter play right exactly yes
so we're looking to equalize the
lifetime score here yeah but happy
birthday on whatever happy happy
birthday
yep happy birthday
all right so we're going now for the
second rank so we can we can little over
a quick checkmate over there so we got a
bouquet two coming in next and there's
nothing you can do about it there's
nothing you can do about just trying to
escape you know to checkmate but it
ain't gonna work
yeah all right he hangs the bishop well
we'll just take it it's not a trick it's
not a trick he's hoping that maybe we'll
still made him but he's going for the
angry rook like the stalemate trick yeah
with the angry rook you know where you
can just check you forever and then you
know yeah so as you as you see once your
material up it's always a good idea to
trade everything off the boards so
alright Oh does he have a trick like
rook takes g6 doesn't worried yeah
because of wreck f8 alright oh good you
always gotta look for tricks like that
anyone else in the chat wants a game a
lot of people do a brain hacker
I saw brain hydrogen let's get brain
hacker again oh right brain hacker yep
now is your shot yeah impress Mike and
maybe you can make it to the team that's
what the summer series was all about but
unfortunately our fortunately for us
they got rid of their rating cap so our
board for is now believe it or not the
Bacchus played board forward for us
Nicholas Theodore has played board four
and of course Liam Lee also has played
board four and we'll be playing board
for against the California unit points
whenever I get the chance of course
because Mike's Mike's pretty harsh he's
generally letting the big guns play but
whenever I get the chance I try to prove
myself you know pretty well they're your
first match right yep yeah I scored 50%
against Chicago
Fidel's okay who did you play in the
last round
kisara and wasn't there wasn't that that
ending kind of funny in that one or
something yeah we we just kept on going
back and forth we were both having a
hard time to figure out a plan yeah and
I figured that like we were even before
the last match so like since we have so
many good players if I I'm just solid
with black then the other guys are gonna
score enough points and that's what
happens yeah if you have Fabiana with
wide you can count on that all right
he's going for some f5 stuff not sure
about that yeah why don't you just why
doesn't he just go back you know Bishop
f6 is a bit of a weird move because we
might have to go back later on anyway to
get our night out you know yep but I
don't know let's expand over here might
be a bit risky what we're doing here
yeah you see we have to put the bishop
back right now
bez mentions the old URIs of gambit club
manager Jonathan Trent's once had a show
and the yourself gambit how to play
against it or with it you got over 1
million views oh so yeah if you want to
check out and add to the total go check
out Jonathan trances your sub gambit
opening ok oh yeah he's going pretty
aggressive here we'll go east 6 if he
takes we'll take back that if for might
be annoying here cuz you can try to gang
up on the e6 pawn but we're not too
worried
because if if stuff is about to get
tricky you know like I'll just ask Mike
for advice 93 so that's not gonna cut it
bro let's let's bring on the night here
yeah so we don't allow any 94 stuff just
gonna go crazy and played g4 o g4 he's
preparing GF Lotus Castle we're safe now
I think I kind of like our position but
it still it's not easy brain hackers
giving us a good game okay he's going
for Queen e1 trying to go for an attack
over there
let's go for let's go for d5 take this
pawn yeah
and if he can go you fine but that pawn
might become weak later on so that's
always something yes right yeah I'm
playing for your knight though all go to
h5 oh man just begging for your guy to
play g4 I don't know why it's not
playing G but it was g4 all go to f4
okay he goes there let's just let's just
I don't know let's just take here and go
94 he can still go E 5 but in my
backfire for him you know 95 okay we'll
go Queen to d7
all right we're attacking the e part
even more so of course your will be
played well rook it for ya it's a move
but we're not worried about stuff like
that okay
and now g4 looks silly yeah he has to do
something with his pieces
and he's almost in the danger zone oh
man he's getting pretty long time let's
try to go for some tricks I feel like it
should work as if he takes we'll take
back of course the oven yeah Oh his bed
crank issues as well so if he takes
we'll take back and then both nights
will be hanging love it so if he moves
this night - yeah he moves it back but
now this guy is hanging so it all worked
out for us and we got the b-pawn to boot
if you want it because it loses the
other b-pawn let's just protect this guy
and this ball is hanging as well yeah
now we activate the rook b3 yeah that's
not gonna cut it
Brooksie - I will just take it
yep d4 let's go 90 to go for some tricks
root do you want you saw it all that guy
let's take here and go for the
archbishop the world champion reigning
champions of the protest leader yep Luis
aren't you finish up time of course the
team manager of the Archbishop's
alongside grand master Benjamin Bach who
is currently 18 and OH can anybody even
give this guy a game Boris Matt and dad
Boris man if we're gonna play you better
you better yeah let's give him again you
better bring it
who cares if you're 1,500 misses to me
yo don't be afraid take the game to them
man it's alright and he goes efore let's
go let's go 9600 let's mix it up this
game 93 will go I don't know once I once
had a video in my beginner breakdown
series let's go tonight of 6 or what
about something about the simple man a
simple move by a simple man I when they
play knight c6 I made it so it was
impossible impossible for you ever to
get in deep
this guy letting d5 on what move for ya
man you got to know what they wanted to
do yeah I was trying to get some she
okay well he gives a pawn we'll just
take it cuz we like pawns over here if
he takes we'll take an e4 yeah so yeah
so you gave Benjamin Bach everything he
wanted in this opening yeah everything
in chess you know like I just want to
take pawns yes yep queen g4 all right is
that gonna scream checkmate oh yeah
thanks made a learn on the board all
right
oh that's I don't know position it's so
good you can do whatever we want you
know let's bring out the Queen that's
what I would do you gonna see this
threat over here ill probably he will I
eat ooh that's my bet yeah 92 Queen g3
let's try to bring out the bishop like
oh that's gonna hurt
that's called voluntarily removing the
defender I love it when that happens
oh man now you got no moves oh yeah 92
well that gives a Baruch and another one
yeah let's give up let's give a check
first you know let's torture him for a
bit and we can take a route so we'll
take it 94 go Queen D Wang he's about to
be checkmate it shout-out to a crisp
dresser thanks for watching the show
thanks let's give a check here let's
give a check here and
oh let's let's bring the bishop back
like it yep we'll take the knight with
the bring in the rook threatening
checkmate Oh
seize it but did he take visit mine
alright no we're not trading off pieces
we're about a check made you a buddy we
show no mercy right alright ok well
let's just give it check and and give it
checkmate that's yeah alright so who's
next
dealer's choice dock pigeon wants to
play rock pigeon we'll give him a game
yep now is your shot doc pigeon so choke
mic the manager what you got Oh nobody
knows this guy could be 14 16 or he
could be a according to one guy playing
with an engine
alright let's play but I doubt I doubt
any of our prestigious viewers are
playing with an engine yeah oh oh he
gives up a pawn
so we'll take his oh okay right off the
bat let's let's keep the bishop Lance
we're we playing for maybe another 20
minutes to a half hour or so so get your
challenges soon see if we can go 25 and
Oh yep so he's got some comp you can't
it's not easy but we're pretty solid
here but he's oh he's down upon but his
pieces are active yep 95 we'll just
castle kick it away with these six on
the next move
did you castle first because maybe you
were that takes up seven gives up
another pong but we already have one
pawn so let's not be greedy all right
oh the night it's a bit too much
oh I guess he thought you were gonna
pre-move Bishop takes oh he was gonna
prove it yeah it's yeah it's only
pre-move take-backs automatic take-backs
anything else is you're bound to fail
yeah
risk is too high right all right um we
can let's just develop the rook he goes
494 and we'll take that pawn our Bishop
is active again
this looks pretty easy yeah so come on
down to the st. Louis chess club today
you have until 2:45 to register for the
Sunday six players Swiss two prizes in
each section forty dollars to the winner
twenty dollars for a second place
and get all the glory you can and who
knows if I'm top of quad - I'll be
playing our section - this is a sick
universal
alright so we're going for some tricks
here we're going to checkmate
I'm just checkmate but also night of
three
yeah night of three let's get it
wonderful yep - we'll just take the rook
and we'll we'll just take right there
I'm going to a night of sick got him on
the run 94 is coming in if he wants
let's just give a check here all right
oh we got a lot of discovered sex coming
where do we where do we give the check
Mike let's let's play check here okay
King up - let's give another check do
you see the checkmate
maybe Bishop f3 may I'll just listen to
you like you don't take it from here
call the moves Mike how about let's be
funny Bishop to d1
okay
if you move the King Knight f3 jib that
big oh and here we go
don't take the Queen we don't need it as
you know the Queen's only worth nine
point the goose is worth nine billion
Queen to the people - checkmate is
coming up all right
oh yeah so cold I keep saying he's gonna
he's gonna give you a better game Tekoa
team code
he's like I'm gonna give you guys a game
you never seen before eleven Seven
Samurai is that Jay Jay
uh Oh could it be he wants to take your
your claim
oh this so this could be Jamil John
Allen a Maratha
Grandmaster and intense chess
victor against I Fatah yep
did you see the big the big match the
intense just meant yeah I saw it it was
a fun to watch
did you see the big tiebreaker yep I was
hopefully I was hoping they would
arm-wrestle but unfortunately they
didn't I think this could be Jay Jay so
we have a we have a real match here
Bishop d6 I don't know let's just let's
just put the bishop back all right he
goes for death let's go Bishop e5 I
don't notice here here probably he knows
better than me a six we'll just take
that and play Queen a four it's a b7
coming up yeah yep
Queen c7 we'll play Queen to a three so
if he takes this guy is hanging hey if
he takes we'll just take back
oh and he blundered a bishop not on no I
just can't be jay-z I didn't think so
hey I think he would have stuck with his
trademark last seven say more I don't
think it would have abbreviated it and
to make matters yes that is seven
summarize had a thing like well I've
never got to the origin of his name yeah
but then yeah last Seven Samurai is on a
twitch channel that is a fellow world
champion of the adjust Liga yeah so if
you guys want to see some quality chess
by each a Jade go to his twitch channel
and you'll have a good time
so we still get about 20-25 minutes in
the thing and we're going to be 25 and
oh how much are we now according to the
ledger 20 and oh but oh oh there it is
it's matter we might have lost count we
might not have I don't know how official
that graphic is but 94 he's going for
checkmate are we afraid it's accurate we
have confirmation where it's accurate
yep that's our illustrious producer Ben
Simon of st. Louis wrestling Fame all
right we got a nice night here on c5 and
his favorite event of course is the
Royal Rumble and he usually goes to all
the WrestleManias where's the
WrestleMania gonna be in March Ben Tampa
all right going down to Florida damn
alright let's you know like that's good
rid of this night just to go back to h6
I guess and then we'll do some more
damage here on the Queen side I like it
and he's down to 40 seconds so all you
sit down a full piece okay yeah we'll go
Queen before
Dakotah he's keeps adding he's like I'm
gonna give you guys a game I'm gonna
give you guys like game well that's like
all right if we can find your challenge
will accept it okay Koda what's his
username or no yeah his name is a Chris
dresser but yeah his username was too
cold or too cool we'll look for it okay
do you see the trick Mike do I see the
trick it's white to move yep white to
move there's a Bishop to e5 again Bishop
to be a Oh Bishop to be even better
yeah even better he trapped his own room
that's tough to do it's tough to do and
now he doesn't know what to do
yeah he's about a timeout we see if he
takes he gets backward checkmated I
guess he's yep okay let's see if we can
find Dakota Dakota do you see him I
don't know let's go with Jesus Christ
all right Jesus Jesus Chris see what you
got d4 I don't know
it's plain this guy's been waiting for a
while to play so yeah so maybe I was
gonna bring it maybe he's gonna bring it
go take the pawn don't take the pawn or
a passed the first test
yep and we're we're taking this pawn so
as to do 93 all right
tricky guy oh we have to be careful here
he might jump with a night suddenly so
let's just cover d5 nice nice move by
Jesus Chris because you don't want to
play move like Queens you want cuz
that's kind of passive so he says
Landing you have the beep on well yeah
some get some tricks over there so I'm
being careful you're alright let's just
let's just castle Age 3 well but now
he's asking for it
he's asking for it I can just take the
pawn if I want to but I don't know if I
want to see how Grand Master's played
they never underestimate their opponents
no matter what their rating may be or no
matter how bad they were playing in the
past they always just they're always on
alert right yeah maybe if you've noticed
in these 21 games 22 games how many
times has Benjamin been checked maybe
twice Bishop b5 check Bishop takes d7
check yep I think those are only two
checks I counted so far maybe one spy
check at the very end but yeah so now we
got a nice position because we have
we've traded is d4 pawn for our C pawn
and we have nice half open C foul on
which we can put some pressure so Queen
to c4 all right do we want to trade
Queens
now we don't let's keep it more fun for
the people
so this guy's doing pretty well on time
so far jacking your queen we'll take it
and we'll bring out night to be for the
taking a lot of screen to be three is
coming up well then we can take them see
- well I don't have anything better so
well but let's uh we gotta watch out
because if work takes C 2 a 3 right
well that hangs the bishop over there
okay don't listen to me Rick see to it
is Rick see to it is let's just stick
with it mm let's just stick with a night
all right here goes the Queen's yep
okay he goes through dere little bull
bring back the night there comes a three
yeah okay we'll just take back a three
we can just move the night back if you
want to or Bishop f5 you know okay let's
go night 95 first it's a page two if he
knows what's oh just take it right let's
just go night here wants to get the
light squared Bishop another dark square
bishop I see I would have doubled his
pawns in a heartbeat and now we got a
pasty pawn and it's all gravy but that's
why LS 17 let's keep the night cuz the
night it's pretty strong over here you
know it's really bugging white and you
can defend this bond over there
wonderful always thinking five steps
ahead now just oh good double your paw
yeah well he also taking our palm but
we'll just protected yeah we're not in
stomach we're not fouling for any cheap
tricks here Bishop c4 we'll take it
yep so we're two pawns up and we're up
on the clock
what more do you want okay let's bring
the knight back to e4 she goes [ __ ]
before that would allow some ePHI tricks
yep
it's too bad so I has to play f3 here
just the same or maybe he'll play Bishop
T what is it
he takes yep oh that's another piece
yeah double attack oh but what about
Bishop to d5 Knight of 6 we got it all
covered under control it is in the red
alright everyone's rich 22 no going for
25 and oh so maybe two or three more
games you know anyone in chat wants to
play that one guys still asking do we
have we ever found him Darko don't find
zone - yeah let's give master oh yeah he
was talking he was talking that he had
some something for you the master of
chests what was he saying before
let's bring out the night we got a grand
master of chess yeah and we got Michael
wait wait wait international arbiter
Michael take cover
alright and I will be an action today so
he gave us a pawns
alright already a gambit of pawn oh we
have to be oh I wasn't careful here oh
you know I play I might have messed that
it might have messed us up Mike cuz when
I play c6 he takes in Queen of three so
okay so if you see that you've done
something wrong don't like compound the
air just just you know play some
patchwork and we'll be fine great cuz
right we're already up a pawn right so
even if we get back upon we're even okay
so got a look on the bright side
sometimes
and get on with the show yeah well our
position here might be kind of
problematic but well we'll deal with it
we've we've dealt with worse situations
you know let's bring on the night yep
just get our pieces active it will be
fine oh you so it's not a thing it's not
a trick it's oh yes some Queen h5 stuff
well let's play Knight b6 let's push him
back
hey need to play it anyway what
no Queen h5 like if we took on g2 he had
Queen h5 and it would have been tough to
protect this pawn oh he's gonna play
Bishop takes f7 we're not them yeah and
he can't go Bishop f1 here but that's
really passive you know he's not playing
Bishop f4 yeah he's not gonna make fool
of us like that
I don't know why I just doesn't go for
it anyway just play Bishop takes f7
check then King takes all right now he's
allowing this stuff again so we'll take
it let's see what you got yes checkmate
let's go e6 if he takes we can cover
with the Queen seven so this probably
will take why there's no excuse for
romantic this is probably the toughest
game we've had so far yeah like I said
cuz I wasn't really careful in the
opening but see that's that's how you
have to beat the grandmasters take the
game to a right away don't don't be uh
I'm gonna play real nice and solid
you're never gonna beat a grandmaster
doing that alright so we got the rook so
he has to show us some real calm down
save the bishop get that Bishop off of a
tree that is mission now get them back
in the game
alright if you say so
oh yeah position like we're upper rook
but it's still not so easy because it's
not easy to develop let's just play I
don't know Queen here and try to bring
out this bishop but he's got a nice comp
you know like he's got a lot of nice
squares not easy not easy for us to make
good news here but okay we got the rook
we got a bit more extra time so 9f5
coming in quick followed by 97 check but
n we just shuffle the King to d8 okay so
yeah let's let's move the Queen over
here try to grab some more material like
I said even five nine takes up seven our
Queen takes up seven obviously oh thanks
for imagining that um but I think I have
to do it anyway he moves there I have I
have Bishop d5 if he takes I will be on
the lookout for word this is 96 i tails
it's gonna do and the knights in a panda
yes you probably a through ninety six
anyway but I'll just take it and he's
not threatening checkmate cuz we got our
Knight yeah we got a night here and
let's just be greedy and there's no
checks no checks so it's all yet so he's
threatening the pig okay well he's
starting nothing now he he collapsed at
the end but yep oh yeah but kudos to a
master chess because he he gave us a
real fight and even though it doesn't
look like
the stuff in the opening so kudos to
master of chess he really went for it
yeah that's how you gotta be
that's how you gotta be you got nothing
to lose you playing 300 against world
champion of the protest League of who's
next let's play wasp nests whoever you
want to play yeah yeah I think he's
fight us a couple I've seen them in the
UH I've seen them in the cube before
though be for what is that buddy let's
go d5 let's let's just bring out the
bishop this is called the orangutan you
say so
all right yeah okay I've seen this
before eeeh yeah we'll go a night of six
and he saved this whole go oh let's just
let's just develop I always find these
pawns annoying because I I can put the
knight on c6 now bit okay we'll just
castle and let's play c5 if he takes
here we're not bridge we'll take back
with the night well you can actually one
of them - or goading them to do it but
he didn't he didn't fall for it
alright let's defend the night here d4
we'll just take here if he takes back we
have 96 yep
alright let's just let's just develop
rixy aid oh we almost got back to a
hundred ninety six players watching now
yep it's just a good time to mention
because we will be going off air in
about ten minutes here tune in tomorrow
Monday 3:15 p.m. and watch the
Archbishop's play the California eunuch
ins we'll have our our four highest
rated players playing Fabiano Wesley
Dominguez and Liam Lee yep we were
favored in all 16 matches against the
California unicorns yeah unfortunately I
won't be playing still still haven't
gotten over that fact like Mike will
have to explain that to me sometime
alright we'll just take here but by
playing that that well but but by
playing that one game earlier in the
season against our rival the Chicago
wind
you are now playoff eligible though yeah
and so the Final Four will be at an
off-site location so you know if our
highest rated players can make it guess
what is always fun and Sam will bring
out the champions from last year again
they're all on our team Wesley Nicholas
Benjamin and Gianna ker wanna write five
yato Ravi I know went seven and a half
out of eight in San Francisco to lead us
to the championship Wesley of course led
us in on the 2017 give each other yeah
those are some real champs like they're
inspiring and everyone around st. Louis
you know was there's a chess fan just
like our my just like our manager
Michael J comer yeah alright so I'm
trying to prevent this night from
developing
um let's just go let's just go rook here
see where he goes oh no all right put
him in a pen put him in a pen all right
I blow the roof everybody is down or one
minute he's down one minute all right
now it's time to get serious all right
um yeah so let's go for some tricks love
it all right we're only only in exchange
down now and we're a minute up on the
clock so and we have these really
annoying nights around here let's try to
get a past clog um well this pin along
the default is really annoying so I want
to do something about that somehow let's
play rook I like it here here comes a
six oh and we'll take we'll take this
guy Queen e2 will trade Queens bring the
knight back threatening threatening a
big check on f3 well first we'll have to
take this guy uh he goes root there good
move we'll go a six trying to round out
that poem Oh Oh dad blunders hey still
has that for though oh yeah okay we'll
take block back and the defense plays
itself yep alright but i got really word
right there yeah police so hung aruch
it's not a not a good idea
especially not when they're when a man
manager is watching you know when you
try to get on the team and you blow on
the roof like manager doesn't like that
money persevere just like the
Archbishop's they're always persevere
we're champions of the world
yeah and here's our proof though prove
it bring back tonight
and we'll just round up that pawn over
there
efore are we scared of that no let's
grab another pond let's grab another
poem
let's greven oh those stupids know he is
the but did he did it did he resign yeah
I resigned right when it was almost a
stalemate
all right we're 24 and oh do we have
time to go 25 and Oh yep let's play this
guy snotter one more where this is 425
and oh and then I gotta go direct the
Sunday six players Swiss that's gonna be
held right here at the Chess Club three
to five all right he's going d4 we're
going again for a fee on keto or a
modern defense whatever you want to call
it very exciting stuff thank you all for
yet for watching today thanks for
everyone those watching the last this is
the last game of the match go 25 and oh
yeah we improved from 1600 at 2246 yep
that's so if you want to get that rating
up Justin by knee to the chest clock and
we'll try to get to 3k next time yeah
thank you for spending some of your
birthday weekend with the people yep big
fans on YouTube all right pretty much
fun yeah okay so we have another Kings
Indian defense here he's all right let's
go
so if anybody wants to play you in
person is there any big open tournament
you'll be playing in the near future do
you know you'll be playing in the US
collegiate rapidly in March that will be
held it's Lou Joe if you're a college
player I want to come out and try to
take on the silver medal champion of the
rapid a blitz of play someplace yes try
to try to get on on that and you'll be
playing in the Pan Am's most likely are
the final four the final yeah so they
went to the Pan Am's
they achieved their goal of getting into
the Final Four yep what kind of cup is
that called again the president's coat
yes Presidents Cup is that held in oh
that's gonna be hell it's Charlotte oh
the pennants were held in short of the
pants final force probably gonna help in
New York City yeah yeah that's where it
was last year all right that hasn't been
confirmed yet so we'll see yep yep but
it will be very exciting we'll be
cheering on Slough of course Webster
made it again yep thank you for Ronin
returns all right please we share you
guys watching you max Branco have you
had a dollar for every win today you'd
have $25 all right all about the
Benjamins
all right the bonus are sorry we
couldn't get to you today we just did
not find you in the queue if you're not
in the queue guess what we can't play
we're not gonna actively seek out how to
challenge you okay yeah we got a show to
run here yeah we we have Michael J comer
legend of the Chess Club and this time
is very valuable you know so he doesn't
have time for that all right let's call
it there's an exchange sec yeah but we
want it that we even want it there's no
reason to take it because it's still in
the pen well let's take it all right
just take it yeah I like it get it off
the books
all right let's activate the rook all
right he's coming in he's coming in you
can already see it let's activate the
Queen here try to oh that's why he
didn't play Knight g5 because they go
yeah well he probably should have played
95 you know cuz like he's down in
material so that's probably and you
should try to go for some tricks but he
didn't so we'll try to convert this
extra I like her I like our chance as I
like our 10 minute on time and things
are looking good yeah so we traded out
the Queen's this pawn might become weak
ninety-two well not sure how he's gonna
defend the pawn right now yep thank you
very much
g3 we'll just move the route back and
we'll put this rook here trying to go d5
Knight g5 alright
China now it's too late - yep too late
buddy
and he's about to lose on time we don't
show any mercy around here
no mercy because I expect nothing from
your opponent so yep it's a great
philosophy yep so he's given up the
night and that's it yep
we went 25 and oh great job Benjamin yep
that's what we like to see in our fellow
Archbishop's uh no mercy relentless 25a
no never give an inch hardly ever get
checked and that's what we like to see
congratulations give a grand German
grand master Benjamin Bach on his
birthday weekend spending it with the
people yeah so thanks for everyone who
watched who challenged us and yeah I
hope everyone enjoyed the games but you
guys have to step it up for next time
make sure to tune in tomorrow to see us
take on the California unicorns 3:15
p.m. USA central time it's gonna be a
great one
let's let's see you get another win get
that championship a la they just keep
keep pressing it on go for no tomorrow
and see what happens yep things everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you